when Alberto Riva won the presidential
election as an outsider in 2002 many
believed Colombia was falling apart
parks rebel group was stronger than ever
violence and kidnappings were daily
occurrences making the country
synonymous with a failed state the only
item on the political agenda was war
with the rebels Uribe was the man for
the job
so he's immensely popular because he
captures this imagination of the
strongman the person who delivered
results on this program on this problem
that we seem unable to tackle a shrewd
and very charismatic politician with a
populist streak he governed with an iron
hand assisted by billions of dollars
sent by the United States he
successfully pushed the guerrilla group
back into the jungle but his success
came at a cost his administration
particularly during a second term was
beset by corruption and human rights
abuses his secret service was found
guilty of supplying a list of suspected
rebel sympathizers to right-wing death
squads and thousands of innocent
Colombians were killed by the army and
presented as rebels to boost statistics
I think our long history with the armed
conflict has inoculated us to some of
the human dimensions and consequences of
the conflict right people don't care if
some human rights are trampled in the
process doubts about to Revis methods go
back to the beginning of his career as
he was accused of connections with drug
cartels including Pablo Escobar and of
being the mastermind behind the creation
of bloodthirsty paramilitary groups yet
despite hundreds of investigations he
has never been charged until now es un
hombre muy popular he remains popular in
a sector of society in this has
protected him his party still his duty
percent of the vote and is an
institutional fear to touch him the
president is his man secondly these
investigations haven't prospered until
now various witnesses and paramilitary
trials have been killed
investigations start but for one reason
or another
since leaving office he has remained
popular and divisive equally hated and
glorified from a Senate seat he has led
the opposition to the peace deal with
the FARC and propelled current president
even dukkha a political unknown to
victory
now he's for the first time expected to
face the country's Supreme Court living
an entire country in suspense alison
ramp et al Jazeera Bogota